you know the episode is going to be good
when it opens with no dialogue and only
Ramin jawadi's score kind of hearkening
back to the trial of the seven it really
submerges you into the tense atmosphere
that we left off on and even the
cinematography AIDS this oncoming Doom
feeling the camera slowly creeping
through this nighttime version of the
red keep makes the tone feel so Eerie I
also love the fact that they don't show
viserys's body and play up the suspenses
to what is going down most people should
be able to put together what's happening
but I like how we have to infer what is
going on instead of being told that the
good old show don't tell and they did a
great job of that by focusing on Allison
and Otto's initial reaction to viserys's
death surprisingly I thought Allison
would be much colder towards viserys and
she ended up being very compassionate
essentially setting up the conflict of
the episode since her reaction of
viserys's death is harshly contrasted by
Autos this leads into the small council
meeting which ended up being my favorite
scene of the episode the ending was
pretty crazy with rhaenys but this scene
was insanely riveting and I was glued to
the screen to see how each character
would react the Hostile takeover the
fact that Otto has been planning for
this event is so satisfying because the
man finally gets a florist as ill
intense I've been craving for this man
to finally unleash his true power and he
is really turning into Tywin Lannister
here also I like the turn that Allison
immediately nopes out of being on Otto's
side and instead wants to handle things
in her own way I thought they would both
work together here but their opposition
made for a surprising turn in the plot
so even though team black doesn't show
up here there is still some heavy
conflict because the ramifications as to
who gets aegon first are catastrophic
but going back to the small council
meeting the death of Lord beesbury
despite him not being a prevalent
character was very striking because
everyone in the audience will sympathize
with this man and his outrage in this
apparent takeover attempt but when sir
Kristen Cole enters the background of
the frame you know [ __ ] is about to go
down down his death essentially sets the
bar and that Otto is not messing around
and intends on getting his hands dirty
like the man didn't even care about
removing the body from the room and
wanted to finish the meeting first what
a mad lad then Harold westerling finally
opposes Kristen Cole and that little
Showdown is what I've been longing for I
also love the amount of shots that
featured Harold westerling here because
his reactions to what everyone is saying
were so visually expressive because we
know that he was pretty loyal to the
targaryens and what he is witnessing is
making him sick a man driven by Honor
and doing the right thing is just
absolutely appalled to what is
transpiring so for the editors to keep
cutting back to his reactions was very
cathartic to me I hope he has more of a
role later on in the story because I
love to see this man wreck Kristen Cole
in the future because in this season he
hasn't had much to do besides just
standing in the background that's why I
got very excited when he confronted
Kristen on top of the man needing some
punishment then the episode shifts
toward the race between Allison and Otto
and fine aegon to me this is where the
episode lost its hot streak of me being
on the edge of my seat because the
episode slows down a lot as we go
through King's Landing in this search in
terms of a writing perspective nothing
is wrong with this and it's a great form
of conflict to have between Allison and
Otto but as a byproduct of this long
hunt and made the episode a lot slower
lost was that feeling of a hot Blitz as
everyone was trying to keep everything
under wraps and control what was
happening it was nice to flesh out some
of the Shady things that happened in
King's Landing but when this is the
penultimate episode of the Season you
expect a little bit more productivity in
the narrative but was it bad not really
I just feel like it would have made
things way more interesting if Vernier
and her family were there when visceros
died because I thought that was the
notion since rhaenys was still in King's
Landing but I guess she stayed there for
whatever reason they made it come across
that this was the day after the last
episode because I assumed the final
scene in the episode 8 took place right
after the Last Supper so I was
definitely confused throughout the
episode and thought the creators were
intentionally holding off and showing
our nearest perspective if team black
was there that could also bring up the
fact that Otto would try to kill them
instantly that would definitely raise
the stakes a lot and would keep the
tension really high throughout the
episode instead of it dissipating as
everyone searches for aegon for like 30
minutes it would definitely be
questionable if Rainier's family would
be able to survive Otto's wrath since he
could probably kill them in their sleep
but you never know maybe Damon has his
suspicions and has precautions in place
for that event along with the fact that
Allison would immediately try to protect
them given that she was also one of the
first people to hear about viserys's
death but I assume there's already a
path in place for our nearest story so I
can't make a judgment as to if they
should have been in King's Landing not
to mention that originally in the books
rhaenys and ranier's crew weren't in
King's Landing during this whole event
then we have the most shocking scene in
the episode that isn't rainey's busting
through the floor but instead let her
strong busting all over Alice feet this
was definitely something I didn't see
coming and I was starting to get
uncomfortable when Allison was slowly
taking off her shoes but hey I guess she
has to pay back this man somehow given
that she's practically in debt to him
I'm kind of sad though that there won't
be a lot of conflict for her to pay him
back in larger ways and the man just
wants some footsie time unless if he'll
want both in the future to me it feels
like kind of a cop-out in that regard
but it seems like lyrics may be going
after Otto's feet next this man's goals
are far greater than our understanding
it's going to be like Robert Baratheon
where instead of making the eight he
wants to cream on all the most powerful
feet in the realm before going into the
ending of the episode I want to touch on
a few notable scenes Otto Hightower
instilling fear amongst the Lords was
very unsettling and seeing the reactions
of different Lords and their ideals was
great I wish we spent more time here and
even the writers showing us their
executions to further emphasize how
scary Otto is here the because I'd
rather we see that instead of watching
The kingsguard Wander on the streets for
a long duration which Eric and Eric and
them also being twins was such a
confusing Duo of characters to follow in
this episode especially since the
writers were trying to portray
development through them and they're
changing motivations I still have no
idea who was who and I wish they didn't
make them twins because for new
characters who had a brief amount of
time who looked the same and basically
have the same name was really hard to
follow it just feels like the writers
are trolling Us in that regard Helena
being an Oracle and randomly spouting
out hints of the future will definitely
keep me paying attention to her she's
such a precious little creature and then
the last thing before moving on to the
ending the confrontation between Otto
and Allison was great because Allison
has finally seen Otto for who he truly
is it kind of helps that rainey's helped
Alice since your metaphorical
imprisonments so her taking control
investing Otto was a good turn that
inatto was kind of proud of Alison for
winning and that was really cute of him
then their debate about whether it's
better to kill a few people to spare the
realm for an oncoming war was really
good very much like Taiwan in regards to
the Red Wedding and his debate with
Tyrion any scene with Otto Nelson is
basically perfect in my eyes and they
are both very rich characters then
finally we have the coronation of aegon
I love how the writers were able to
quickly sell aegon's Ark primarily
through acting in a tiny bit of dialogue
a character going from being rejected
all his life and being entrenched in the
scum of humanity to getting loved
worshiped and accepted was really sweet
and made me care a lot for aegon with
just a couple of scenes aegon goes from
a lost cause to someone that is really
relatable and likable so that's pretty
impressive from a writing standpoint and
I'll be very interested to see aegon
change of heart and being King in the
future episodes then the controversial
twist happens where iranies bust through
the floor of the Dragon pets from what
I've seen this is a major change from
the books so some people are upset by
this moment and say it's for the sake of
shock value and is dumb given that rainy
spares everyone now the writing here
isn't perfect and there are some minor
plot holes but I think this scene would
be much better if there was a threat
pushing rainey's out of the building
instead of her leaving on her own accord
I feel like the most natural thing would
be to have some archers posted on the
upper decks as a normal defensive
measure to pressure rhaenys and that is
the reason she needs to get out you can
still have the moment where she
approaches the greens but instead of
making a decision as if she roasts them
alive or not make it ambiguous since
she'll need to flee before we find out
if she'll kill her own family so if
that's the case we now don't have a
reason to get upset about this plot
point and I've also seen people say to
have another Dragon come out of the pit
which could also work but that would
kind of confuse me because I'd assume
e-track would have their own designated
areas and aren't freely roaming around
everywhere in the pits in terms of a
character perspective and rainy's not
killing the greens I can kind of
understand that decision primarily her
not wanting to be responsible for
incinerating like half of her family
also I can see her sparing Mercy on them
since Allison essentially did the same
to rainey's earlier in the episode and
didn't just flat out kill her during the
coup that and since she's witnessing the
entire population of King's Landing
support this new male ruler she's
probably thinking back to when she lost
the throne and thinks people won't
accept Rainer because of tradition now
but yeah it's definitely flawed and even
if the writers are saying that people
are going to have issues with it then
you know they screwed up it's a complex
choice and one that people might dispute
or have a problem with but that's the
choice rainey's makes in that moment you
know great heroic moment for her
character
it comes across as the writers wanting
to give rainies a bigger moment since I
guess she doesn't have one in the source
material so that she can have a larger
impact which is nice but I wish they
took the time to rewrite the scene so it
makes more sense they could have easily
established an external force of the
terrainis from having to make this
pivotal decision that people will get
mad over besides this the episode was
still pretty good but I think there's a
few flaws that drag it down a bit to not
classify it as being one of the best
episodes in the season thank you for
watching and let me know what you
thought about this episode of House of
the Dragon in the comments
foreign